dr colleen darnell hunts for clues to
solve the mystery of why dozens of
pharaohs were removed from their
original tombs and reburied in an
unmarked grave
[Music]
could this ancient papyrus hold the
answer one of the more remarkable
documents to survive from ancient egypt
is a transcript of the confessions of a
tomb robber
the papyrus was long ago torn down the
middle
the two halves now live in different
museums
but by bringing the pieces together
colleen can decode the ancient
confessions of a new kingdom tomb robber
named amanpaneffer who broke into the
tomb of a pharaoh named sobekimsaf ii
we took
our copper
tools
and we broke into its very inner
chamber and we know that they're going
through the mummies themselves because
they talk about a piece of gold jewelry
at the neck of the king
amen ponefer admits to digging a tunnel
into the tomb of the pharaoh
once inside he took as much gold as he
could carry
but he was caught
for his crimes a brutal punishment
sentenced to death by impalement
this tomb robbery and others like it
alarms new kingdom authorities
their pharaoh's mummies so sacred to the
ancient egyptians aren't safe
the authorities take action
in order to safeguard the royal mummies
they were moved re-wrapped and buried
together in an unmarked tomb
we know that the plan worked by moving
them from the valley of the kings to an
unmarked tomb
they survived for thousands of years
[Music]
you